we live in a new era of social media  everything is changing and everyone  tries to stand out in this noisy crowd  we need to make a difference and  animation is the key because it attracts  more attention maybe this sounds  complicated but i'm here to help you  there is a live workshop coming with the  future together we're gonna explore the  easiest way to create animated instagram  carousels we're gonna cover everything  from a to z  starting from how to find new ideas  how to write the script easily by using  special tools even for non-native  speakers like me  and finally how to design the posts give  them life with animation and convert  them into different formats for other  social media platforms if you want to  learn more click the link in the  description  you